parler de vincent lagaf vincent lagaf
voilà qui sera ce soir dans ce tract sur
ces vies très serré que tout le monde
m'en a parlé de cette histoire puisque
voilà il ya eu il a fait des
déclarations qui n'ont peut être pas
plus à la chaîne mais sachez le dans la
chaîne on se dit tous et comme thierry
et moi comme voilà nous ici avec les
chroniqueurs on vous a fait un petit
récap parce que tout le monde voulait
savoir ce qui se passe entre la gaffe et
c8 regarder le 30 mai dernier ses 8
annoncés en grande pompe le retour de
vincent lagaf à la télé la chaîne et
cyril hanouna lui ont concocté un jeu
sur mesure stripe dès la première
diffusion l'émission est un véritable
carton d'audience
et pourtant contre toute attente
l'animateur de strike évoque déjà la
possibilité de quitter ses 8,6 tf1 me
dis ton idée d'émission de sports
mécaniques nous branche
on la veut le dimanche après midi j'y
vais aux coupes
une intervention qui fait grincer des
dents du côté des patrons de ces vite
comme cyril a annoncé dans cette
émission que je peux dire c'est que j'ai
eu les dirigeants de ces huit ce week
end et que cette sortie est extrêmement
mal passé convoquera avec bien sûr les
dirigeants de ces huit pour vaud
l'accueillir août avec nous ou téva déco
selon nos informations vincent lagaf
pourrait être convoquée le 8 octobre
prochain
alors d'après vous la gaffe at il perdu
la boule alors c'est vrai alors moi je
vais défendre un peu vincent soir mais
je sais que vous êtes très énervé baala
pour là où il y en a qui ont agacé
énervé vous tous est ce que vous le
comprenez voilà il peut dire des trucs
pas je sais que mathieu est un peu
énervé il a dit ce qu'ils pensaient
jean-michel ces mercenaires quoi il va
là au plus offrant a donc des quelqu'un
met plus d'argent que la chaîne
concurrente qui est bon tu as une
famille parce qu'il à l'équipe assyriens
il avait même dit la première mission
avant que le début de ce qu'il avait dit
si la première marche après faudra
mettre beaucoup de zèle pour jaurès et
ghzaya que la reconnaissance qu'on
tourne à copenhague ont été signés moi
je comprends très bien qu'ils y
peut-être je vais faire autre chose
après 95 émission programmée à la suite
fait donc 15 semaines ce genre de
sorties s'cusez moi pour une chaîne ce
n'est pas audible c'est pas possible on
rêve c'est un corporate ça se fait pas
du tout même si on n'a pas de contrat de
l'ex comme on dit on se tait et on dit
peut-être après mais pas appelle papa
comme ça gilles j'ai hâte de voir
comment vous allez le défendre parce que
ce qui fait là avec tf1 et vous alors il
veut mais tu veux mettre un coup de
pression
je suis pas du reste arbres il fait
monter les enchères ni plus ni moins
il dit retenez moi sinon j'y vais si
vous me prenez mon mag automobile givet
combien d'argent vous me donnez ça vous
détestez donc je vois pas comme cyril
valery loi de nationale 3 et 7 face à
l'as je comprends pas le bruit d'autant
que d'autant que fokam dire la vérité du
coup aux gens c'est 15 prime time qui
ont été tournées en huit jours voilà ces
huit jours de travail avant les libres
mais peu importe ce que je voulais dire
c'est que derrière on retrouve in voici
alors je vais revenir sur le deuxième
idée les premiers à dire qu'il n'était
pas le bienvenu visiblement j'avais
raison j'ai pas fini 3e mais tu es jeune
tu es fou mais une troisième chose moi
je leur donne tout et dieu sait si on a
tous fait des erreurs de communication
connaît tous des heures dans cette
émission en direct je pardonne tout aux
gens qui s'excuse et qui reviennent sur
le propos est ce qui s'explique or
depuis toutes ces sorties tous ces
dérapages depuis qu'on en a parlé le
reçoit pas un mot de lui et continuer
dans les structures dont il entend tout
ce qui se dit autour il en aura dans
l'aventuré robinson temps passe plus les
vannes où c'était une troisième caudry
[Rires]
j'aime pas les gens qui font des
conneries et qui sait ce qu c'est trop
facile de s'excuser tout le temps je
rejoins benjamin il a fait le mercenaire
comme on dit il vous l'a fait à l'envers
et il aurait dû se taire il a signé ses
prime il fait ses preuves à leurs amis
sont diffusées il n'a pas besoin
d'ouvrir d'ouvrir sa bouche de dire je
vais à tf1 si tf1 il est en train de
faire des pâtés de sable à cavalaire
personne l'a calculé il était tout seul
à cavalaire arsenal parler arrive assez
vite on lui ont fait jouer au bowling
arriver là il veut partir à tf1 moi je
te dis vincent je t aimais beaucoup
alors à l'appel du guide vaches et f1
fait de la place 20 ans et j'espère que
vous vous n'allez pas le reprendre après
si robien
je suis sentie lagaf lagarde il a
toujours hâte en jeu deux minutes qu'il
faut pas oublier quand même que depuis
le début la toujours été honnête sur ce
qu'ils allaient faire et c'est facile a
concédé au total traqué lors du coup
maintenant c'est de ce côté c'est
nouveau ce titre le prévenu qu'il allait
être comme ça et on l'a dit depuis le
début c'est s'il a dit ça après tout
faut qu'on est un [ __ ] qu'on excuse
a dit il a dit il a dit dès le départ
qu'il n'y avait pas d'exclusivité
oui moi je trouve quand même très
choquant de vous quelqu'un qui a été
justement dans l'ombre pendant des
années de ressusciter si vous permettez
l'expression à ses huit étaient à tâter
à peine sorti la tête de l'eau qui était
déjà en train d'aller manger qui est
celui qui taxe navire et qu' on dire il
a toujours fonctionné comme ça quand je
suis et atef je vous jure il disait à
tf1 parce que j'ai vraiment des des
contacts avec des gens voilà de tf1 vrac
non mais non voilà je vous le dis voilà
et même des jeux encore des potes à tf1
news
on est comme ça non mais ça vous le dit
attention c'est une route et nous la
traverser la rue adèle emmanuel macron
struth à barcelone
on a deux places alors il a toujours
fonctionné comme ça quand il était à tf1
ils disaient oui j'ai des procès j'ai
des propositions à france 2 attention je
vais partir si vous me donnez pas ça je
vais partir voilà alors il a toujours
fonctionné comme ça c'était vincent
chancey une grande gueule il est un peu
comme moi mais il est très gentil
quant au fond c'est un gentil mais d'un
an déjà certain de quoi bas de vincent
lagaf je le connais mieux que vous
embauche crois pas non à la sergente
mais j'ai d'autres ajouteront mansuétude
si l'un d'entre nous a pu refuser même
sorti sur un interview oui on aurait un
petit sms de veulent pas des toits
attention vos locations et à makoun dans
la caisse à l'époque de tf1 le contrat
qu'il avait à tf1 qui était gigantesque
oui à l'époque de hervé hubert près nous
faisons précis effectivement il aurait
pu aller ailleurs mais personnes
pourraient le payer ce qu'on peut dire
telle fin et des sorties qui ne servent
à rien c'est l'exclusivité même l'excusé
russie il a dit que ça coûtait alors
déchiré juste et sa vie alors ce soir il
y a strike il est excellent de damrémont
mechouar spécial star 80 en plus voilà
je vous dis je suis producteur
d'émissions et je trouve excellente nous
et je pense que ça a été pour moi le bon
choix de l'animateur franchement il faut
pas dire voilà il fait il est excellent
en dedans et je pense encore que ça a
très bien marché sauve sa marche fort
pour l'instant strike alors on va voir
ce que vous en pensez vous vous a posé
la question
regardez vincent lagaf at il perdu la
tête oui à 60 % non à habas bon à la
soixantaine d'heures mais ça c'est un
voyou pas dire que les arguments au
début du sondage on m'a dit dans
l'oreillette c'était 80 m
jusqu'à 20% à chaque fois je suis
président dans notre voie là